but what do you think about what has
happened in the last 24 48 hours with
Cleveland and what's that mean maybe
from LeBron James future if any I'm
still I just don't understand Dan
Gilbert and how he operates this doesn't
seem like a good time for you to be
bringing in a general manager to learn
on the fly right like hey so you
probably got one year left with LeBron
James bosses out here making these moves
you got a retool to get over the war you
see a perfect time to get a general
manager who's never done this job before
and I just can't figure out how this
winds up being the move I don't think
you can make any argument against the
fact that Griffin did a good job while
he was there so I don't get it but I
guess you know my network has been
running this number that's pretty
fascinating dan Gilbert had reupload a
general manager yet not once
LeBron's gone through some GM's and some
coaches here and then I wonder and I
said this yesterday and I was probably
in the minority but now with David
Griffin fired I just don't see LeBron
ending his career in Cleveland I think
he gave them the championship and it
feels like what he does next might be
just that have fun playing basketball
maybe it's going to Los Angeles for
business reasons I'm not sure it just
doesn't feel like he and Dan Gilbert are
ever going to be best buddies with this
you've got I do by name right like if
you saw that a podcast for the
barbershop a draymond Green referred to
him as the guy who owned the team at the
time right like I ain't seen this level
of open acrimony since shine got out of
jail it was call him puffy dude right
and shine guy I mean probably got shot
sent to jail and he was called him dude
that's a LeBron James deals and talks
about Dan Gilbert so I was talking to
somebody a couple weeks ago about this
where I was like so I heard a few months
ago that LeBron is looking to go to Los
Angeles and the way this game works if
it gets to the point where I heard it I
ain't the only one who write you know
like I'm not I'm not I'm not at the top
of the telephone tree on these sorts of
things so I was talking to God I was
like so what are people going to start
talking about the fact that they'd heard
about LeBron in LA I swear is the next
day we all decided to be like okay so we
could be honest about the fact that we
here at that LeBron is going to LA at
this point I'd be surprised if you
stayed in Cleveland I was going to use
the same shine puffy reference before
you beat me to that but you know what's
great about this leading in
this draft there's a whole lot of
intrigue involving a whole lot of teams
and it all starts and finishes with
Golden State like LeBron it at Golden
State's and everybody's head now it
whatever you're going to do if you want
to compete with us for the next couple
years all right let's see what you got
and it just feels like there's going to
be desperate times desperate measures
here by teams yeah I feel like a lot of
teams though are trying to position
themselves for when this goes and say
thing kind of tapers off because they're
so far away for being able to compete
now everything Cleveland has done for
the better part of the last two years
has been about trying to compete with
Golden State and I mean there's there's
nobody else for them to do but like
that's the white whale that they have to
be the ones chasing at this point so
like that one I think makes a certain
measure of sense Boston's in this odd
position where you can't tell if they're
playing for now playing for later or
somehow they're going to try to do both
right like it's a crazy time in the
league where everybody is trying to
shoot for something that's so far away's
of the different ways to go about it and
kind of different middle ground levels
that I feel like that they wind up at
where they decide okay well this is
what's going to satisfy it satisfy us
right now and all of that leads to a
draft that we're all so excited about
and we know has like six or seven really
good players that hardly any of us have
ever watched playback well they're only
there for six months to have them how
many people watched a full game of
marquel folks a full game like I don't
even know why we need to go that far
lady to think is marquel fools playing
on a team that won nine games and I
don't even know if I can blame him for
it but they played all the West Coast
like with Simmons at least I did watch
Simmons play in to be honest everyone
had been telling us all year about
Simmons last time I found out if I'm
Mark Ellis what am I putting them on TV
like it's going to take a lot more than
Bill Walton calling the game for me to
to an end to watch nine win Washington
just as y'all say to do is good but
Lonzo ball is going to be must-see TV I
think like if I'm a fun I think magic
being a brilliant businessman looks at
this as I've got a player who's going to
play right away and as a businessman
this is must-see TV the Lakers become
very very interesting now just because
Alonzo ball I also think that magic is
doing something that is kind of the
blessing and curse a former player as
executive because one thing that former
players love to do as executives is get
players that remind themselves right he
has been as it
any player this your hat that reminds
you of you and he said yes its Rondo
ball they are all suckers for guys who
remind them of themselves and I got
questions about Lonzo like I don't know
if you like athleticism I have questions
that funny-looking jumper I've got
questions about and watching the air and
Fox will light him up two times doesn't
make you feel better about him
necessarily but magic I don't know if
magic can pass up on some guy that
reminds him so much of himself you know
like allow me a lot of myself when I see
you I loved yearn far
Iida too he's got attitude he's the
fastest guy in the draft he played in a
big program I don't know it feels like
he sort of not involved in the
conversation but and it feels like he's
destined up in Sacramento or something
but I I do like him I think he's a fun
kid to watch Hayes from Houston which
you know those of us who are from you
know yes that's that's it hot as what it
is he's bomani Jones from the mothership
joining us Dan Patrick show a couple
other things here
the Kaepernick conversation continues is
the coverage interesting to you of like
it almost feels like there's a story but
then there's the coverage of the story
what's more interesting oh that's a good
question I think the coverage of the
story has its own level of interest
because all right so we're at a point
now where I just don't feel like anybody
can honestly and sincerely say that
Kaepernick is not capable of playing in
the NFL I just don't think you can I
think you can look at somebody scrubs
that are got in contract and it's hard
to make the play and make the argument
that Kaepernick has no business in the
league now on the other hand I do agree
with those who raised the question as to
whether or not he's really doing the
service buy it for himself by being so
silent at this point like at this point
I feel like you got to go do an
interview and say look this is what has
happened this is what has not happened
so forth and so long because the
questions and everything gets so loud
where if you're not saying anything then
what everybody just left to their own
devices and I don't think that he can
afford to leave people at their own
devices anymore
I just find myself frustrated because if
you want to make the argument that he
can't play in the NFL that's fine like
this is the 21st century get on the
internet put out some chips and explain
to us why it is that he's not capable of
playing the NFL but all the guys I know
who do go on the internet and put out
the gifs of the film all say that he can
play
so like what's going on from this people
from these people on the other side and
I don't know why so many people are so
invested in just dismissing the idea
that maybe just maybe the league is
making a decision to teach him a lesson
as though that's such a like ridiculous
idea that somebody would do no it's
totally possible that that could happen
but I think it's impossible to make the
argument that he's simply incapable of
playing NFL football well I look at
Kaepernick and in this situation I find
fascinating it just feels like
everybody's got their personal beliefs
and then they injected into this story
and then Kaepernick will sign with some
team and nobody's going to care about
Kaepernick after that I think he has to
get out in front of this I don't think
he's helped himself at all I'd love to
know do you think you're a starter are
you willing to be a backup its location
going to be an issue here are you
healthy these are just generic questions
that I would have for him if I was
interested in him let alone you know
doing a talk show but until he says that
then he's I think he's made it murkier
he's made it more of a mystery than it
already should be and I think that
that's a disservice to him I do agree
there but I would also make the argument
on the other side these are all pieces
of information that NFL teams could
probably easily find out with phone
calls that they're not making and the
most damning thing and this remains that
as far as anybody can tell they're not
even calling to find out at the scarcest
position in professional sports
yeah I would bring him in III thought I
find the Browns I would have brought him
in I you know if you think the Shawn
Kaiser is your future I bring in
Kaepernick or the Jets or somebody as a
starter as a backup I don't know you
have to sort of cater your offense or he
has to fit in with that like Seattle
would have been great I think because of
the offense but I don't know what the
politics of the drama behind the scenes
but I still think he can play and I
would take a chance on him but you know
I'm probably you know I disagree with
the argument about having to tailor the
offense to the backup quarterback and
the reason I say that is three different
teams on Michael Vick to be backup
quarterback right who had every single
flag and tag that we have about
Katherine day that people throw out
there about Kaepernick about running
your offense and fit in everything else
three different teams decided to sign
him after he was I mean two of them
after he was getting older and breaking
down so like Derek Anderson is Cam
Newton's back
named Taylor no offense no damn Derrick
Derrick Anderson he felt as a job but
Derrick Anderson can play an approach
set right but the argument is that you
have to tailor whatever it is that
you're doing you have to have a backup
that plays the same kind of game as your
starter because otherwise you have to
change everything when the backup comes
in but they have no problem changing
everything when Derrick Anderson comes
in right like that's why I say that
argument that what we have to table the
offense around the backup and who wants
to do that now I don't I don't really
buy that because I guess I've seen over
all lives you've seen too many
quarterbacks who aren't like the guy who
starts over there yeah but it's it feels
like if you bring him in as a starter
you may be changing your entire offense
because of Colin Kaepernick if he's the
backup I understand if he comes in and
plays that maybe you're not changing
much at all but if you bring him into
the Browns are you a different offense
is your mindset different for Hugh
Jackson because Kaepernick's there as
opposed to starting you know Brock
Osweiler yeah I'd say I think there's
something to that but I'd also say as
much as people want a not Khaled
Kaepernick and all like how complex and
offense you can run how complex an
offense can you run for Cody Kessler or
Brock Osweiler for example right like
I'd like to think that NFL coaches
should be able to be flexible enough to
be like okay we got a different player
where we're going to do things a little
bit differently as opposed to we do this
one way one way only where do you your
reaction to what Tiger had to say
yesterday through his agent that he
needs help for his pain meds well good
for him I mean I think that was
abundantly clear once you saw the video
like generally speaking once you get
pulled over tanked while driving a car
that's typically the sign that okay
something is not right here and so for
him to say okay I've got a problem I
think that there's something too and I
just all you could do in a situation
like this is hope that the dude gets
better because he doesn't want it to be
this way right like it's like I don't
think he started taking the painkillers
for kicks you start taking the
painkillers for pain and then it goes
from there and I think those things get
unwieldy and out of people's control in
a lot of ways just like alcohol gets out
of people's control in a lot of ways
when they're struggling and you know for
different reasons so I just hope you
winds up being okay that's all you can
ask for in a case like that you've got a
new show coming up I do going in January
me and Pablo Torian do a show that as of
yet doesn't have name format or anything
do it damn it wait is it just a TV only
show it is a TV only show at least as
far as I know we're going to a twelve to
one the eastern starting January the
second on ESPN and I gotta say I'm kind
of thrilled Wow why you just called the
no-name show or remember that love is in
America gave us the horse with no name
it's the show with no name I have to say
if we did that it will probably be safer
than any name that Pablo and I write
like that that I do I think that if you
gave like the whole list of things that
he and I would say and then we come over
the show with no name I can't imagine
how quickly the Fosters would be like
yeah show with no name that's one that
works Thank You beau good to talk to you
again no problem bed you guys have a go
well that's bomani Jones from the
mothership the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience